Doppelkreis, oder besser gesagt, P1, wie es an der Prüfung benannt wird, sind zwei Kreise
an einer Landau geflogen, also direkt im Verbindung geflogen, ein und Ausleitung sind aber
auf gleicher Achse, beziehungsweise einfach parallel zu der Achse, wo man begonnen hat, also
ich starte auf der Achse, mache den ersten Kreis, den zweiten Kreis und der Ende vom zweiten
Kreis, das Ende, mehr als parallel zum Beginn von dem ganz 100 min, dann die
und Einstellungen einer gewissen Fährlage und Beendigung dieser Fährlage mit Energiemanagement
kann man sagen, totalisierend.
Okay, ich könnte das Ganze beginnen mit der Bremse am Steg in der Hand geflogen.
Das heißt, ihr nehmt beide Bremsen ganz locker am Steg in der Hand und probiert dann die Bremsen
auf jeden Fall aufs geringste sinken zu ziehen.
Wir starten bei den Manöver mit den beiden Bremsen gezogen auch beim geringsten sinken.
Wir checken immer zuerst, bevor wir dann die Kurvereinheiten auf der Luftraumfreihe ist,
wenn das der Fall ist, dann leiden wir den Rechtskreis ein.
Die Queerlage vom Kreis können wir jetzt mit der Innenbremse etwas definieren.
Also haben wir zwei in die Queerlage, dann ziehen wir einfach die Innenbremse ein langesam
Moment, kommt und die Schirm, wie ein bisschen Queerlage verliert, dann dürfte dann
einmal zwei, drei Zentimeter ziehen, um die Queerlage wieder erneut besser einsstellen.
Und dann kurz bevor wir den zweiten Kreis beendet haben, also kurz bevor wir auf unserem
Fluch sind, gehen wir mit den Körper in die neutralen Stellung und ziehen dann kurz vor unserer
Flucht die Außendbremse nach unten, so dass wir theoretisch wieder beim gering
Statt natürlich die Bremsen müssen nicht so weit herunterziehen, das heißt etwas Bremsen
für das geringste sinken, dann genau gleich vor, links hoch, gewicht recht rein, Queerlage
einstellen, definieren, dann kurz bevor wir auf unserer Flucht sind beim zweiten Kreis,
sagt, neutrale Sitzposition aus dem Hand runternehmen, so dass wir möglichst beidzeitig gepremst
aus dem ganzen Wiederherraus kommen. Und erst danach, sagt, können wir wieder in den
Gleitsflug übergehen. Für den Doppelkreis wird eine vorgegebene Flugaxe
eingenommen. Durch dosiertes Ziehen der rechten Steuerleine werden zwei rechtsdrehende Kreise
ohne Unterbruch innerhalb maximal 20 Sekunden geflogen. Mit frühzeitigem Verlangsamen der
Drehung wird das Manöver auf der ursprünglichen Flugaxe ausgeleitet. Durch dosiertes
Anbremsen werden Nachfolgen der Roll- und Nik-Bewegungen abgefangen und der Schirm wird stabilisiert.
Wichtig, die Zeitmessung stoppt erst, wenn der Schirm stabil auf der ursprünglichen Flugaxe
fliegt.